[Music]
chrissy is with us in
vegas hi chrissy welcome to the ramsay
show
hi dave hey what's up how are you good
how can i help
um okay so i'm on the collection portion
of my dead snowball
um and um i just wanted to
know how i'm supposed to tackle it
because none of these
um places are actually like contacting
me or anything it's
most of them are like two years or more
so i only have their address
and then one of them is also an amex
that's not on my credit report anymore
so i just want to know how to tackle
them because i have all the money
already to pay them
okay good and you don't have any debts
that are active
only old debts that are in collection
that's correct okay list them as best
you understand the balances
smallest to largest contact the smallest
one
and find out what you can settle that
for
because you may think it's a thousand
dollars and they may have run it up to
three thousand and you'll have to
negotiate and get it back down to a
thousand
uh what if they don't have a number it's
only an address on the credit report
you got to find them gotcha just jump
online and start looking for a number
they're out there they got a phone
number
gotcha okay and for the emacs that's not
on my credit report anymore
same thing it doesn't matter if it's on
your credit bureau report or not you
still owe it
got it and they can still come sue you
got it so so here's the rule okay
call them and they're going to act like
that all of a sudden they're
they're uh going to get aggressive which
is
humorous considering they haven't even
contacted you in years right
but they're all sudden going to go and
you're going to go no no
no no no so it's not a thousand it's 3
000 now well i'm not paying 3 000. i i
have a thousand dollars that says you'll
take it
and and you negotiate with them and they
say okay we'll take a thousand dollars
then you have to get that in writing say
in writing chrissy
christie in writing if it's not in
writing it didn't happen when you're
dealing with collectors you can tell
they're
lying if their mouth is moving it's a
scummy business
okay in writing and then do not
give them electronic access to your
regular checking account
because they'll step in there and clean
your butt out okay
okay so you in writing and you can do a
wire transfer or a prepaid debit card or
something else
but no electronic access to your
checking account do not let them have
get into your account because they'll
pull 3000 out after you agree to a
thousand and you're gonna have trouble
getting it back
right so in writing no electronic access
to checking account how many of these
debts are there
um just three and oh it's actually four
including that you mix
okay good luck cause it's gonna be a
hassle
it's not gonna be it's not gonna be like
one phone call and it's done
you're going to have to argue with them
and call them back and hang up on them
and they're going to call you
and it's just going to be a mess do not
give them a bunch of information on you
where do you work none of your business
i'm here on the phone
trying to give you money that's all you
need to know
you got it and you listen i i know
you're you're a sweet person i can tell
by talking to you
i need the not sweet version of you on
the phone with them okay
okay because they're gonna be nasty
now you don't have to be nasty but i
mean you got to be tough you with me
yeah okay in writing no electronic
access to your checking account
that's how you do this stuff